[Music]
hi I'm Mike Seymour from FX guide for
wired one of the great action sequences
of the new Hobbit film the desolation of
smaug is also one of the directors
favorite chapters from the book
basically Bilbo assists the dwarves in
sneaking out of Thanos realm for
woodland realm with the use of empty
wine barrels
what follows is an action-packed
sequence but just how hard is it to film
a scene like that well the entire
finished sequence is seven minutes long
and normally films have a shooting ratio
which is the ratio between the footage
that's shot and the footage that makes
the Edit of ten to one or twenty to one
that's the highest level might be
documentary might be hundred to one so
on the new Hobbit film the sheer
complexity of the amazing sequence
required a much higher shooting ratio
how much higher well the film started by
shooting over four days on three
separate rivers in New Zealand this was
combined with some 11 hours of aerial
footage but that was just the start the
production had planned the sequence out
very carefully and had done a total of a
thousand and ninety-one previous shots
this base water and aerial location work
was combined with thirty-five hours of
dry set green screen footage which were
too digital then added digital water and
some complex digital environments the
team did of course location work they
also built some practical water rapids
it's almost looked like theme park rides
but in the end they still had to put in
a large amount of digital water
simulations each of these complex
simulations averaged over 600 million
particles or simulated down to about one
centimeter resolution plus all of this
water still had to be surrounded by some
40 different CG environments or
landscapes when the work was done an
amazing 98 hours of footage had to be
edited down to the final stunning seven
minutes in the film and the shooting
ratio by my calculations it's 843 to 1o
in case you're wondering yes they did in
fact lose some barrels while filming in
the whitewater rapids of New Zealand's
epic landscape they're still out there
somewhere if you're looking for a nice
piece of Hobbit memorabilia well don't
forget to subscribe for more behind the
scenes action I might see more for white
you
[Music]